hero with seven to shoot
hiro long three-pointer bang tyler
33 for the rookie it's an eight-point
lead as we're under four minutes
remaining
jalen brown rolls around and drops
through a big bucket to respond
kemba walk of the rebound throws it back
up top to jalen brown
brown on the drive stops in the paint
marcus smart
lays it up and in good cut from marcus
smart
and it's a three-point game butler
looking to back in
double-teamed and they're doubling off
iguodala
he's got to be ready to shoot oh what a
move from dragach the crafty left-hander
he clinging to a five-point lead butler
spins
falling away puts it up puts it in jimmy
butler a big bucket
and it's a seven point miami lead under
two to play
a little high screen and rolling jimmy
butler takes matters in his own hands
tatum tries a three it's good jason
tatum continues his tour at second half
and it's back to four again
butler doubled adebayo pass inside
iguodala back out dragon she's wide open
got it
he's holding on to it on the far side of
the court you can see him fallon
extended
jimmy butler four to shoot backing in
backing in
feet inside hiro with a left hand
there's another offensive rebound brings
it back out
finds tatum tatum tries a three it's
good
jason tatum makes it a six point game
with 42.9 remaining
[Applause]
which totally changes the play hayward
throws it into corner to brown hoist up
the three-pointer it's good jalen
good ball denial dragon gets it in the
hero hero double team
dribbles away from that and he's fouled
and i think miami has to really think do
we want to go back zone
or do we want to play man now what
poison confidence
for the 20 year old now with 36 points
calmly sinks two huge free throws
walker trying to draw the foul and he
did butler reaching in but they're
saying it's on the floor
not in the act of shooting according to
scott foster
walker now three or four from the
free-throw line walker also an excellent
free-throw shooter eric spoelstra want
to get duncan robinson
back in the game or is he going to take
his last time out
to advance the ball again
three clutch free throws there for kemba
walker
dragach lobs it up butler with the catch
butler dribbles away
and finally they fall him letting
several seconds go off the clock
quality even second free throws made but
having that one time out
huge first free throw bounces around and
drops in
clutch free throws from jimmy butler and
the celtics will use the timeout it's a
four point lead with six seconds
remaining
looks kemba walker puts up a three in
and out won't go the tip misses the
second tip from haywood is good with
1.8 remaining looks
kemba walker puts up a three in and out
won't go the tip misses the second tip
from hayward is good with
1.8 remaining all he'd have to do is get
it in they get it to butler
and butler is fouled with 1.1 left
and a two-point heat lead two huge free
throws
perfect from the line tonight
and misses that one and can set up to
throw a long pass
i miss i agree
butler hits it celtics need a three
tice throws it the length ball deflected
and that's it
the miami heat take a commanding 3-1
lead in the eastern conference finals